clearly you have a deep fascination with
performance and uh excellence
and maximizing so like where does that
come from
i i didn't really grow up that
interested in the human body
you know aside from the fact that i
owned one um
i i wasn't too interested in in the
mechanics of
how it works uh however
when i was 13 or 14 i discovered the
sport of tennis
and that kind of like pulled me from
being a total geek who was only
interested in like
you know pulling apart the motherboard
on my computer and playing chess and
you know touring around with with
violins and musical instruments and
just you know being a a quintessential
homeschooled
geek uh into being a little bit more
interested in
in physical culture so to speak right
like i remember
my dad took me to guard sports down the
street the local sporting goods store
and
you know because i was playing tennis
and i want to get stronger so i got a
set of
10 pound dumbbells i had no clue how to
use them like the first exercise that i
learned
and this was just based on my own like
intuition was i would like
lay on my belly on my bed and have the
dumbbells
on the on the floor and do like
basically like a preacher curl on my
on my stomach while i'd watch tv just
thinking that you know
well at least it's gonna give me strong
arms for tennis right and then um
i think the second piece of exercise
equipment that i got
was again i saw this on tv it was like
one of those as seen on tv ab devices
it was that one that you that you put
the pad against your
stomach and kind of pull into your
stomach
doing an isometric contraction to make
your abs stronger
so i either damaged a whole bunch of my
internal organs when i was 13 years old
or else
actually you know worked my core a
little bit
but but you know i started running up
the hill back behind my house
and then you know i had a coach i
started doing sprints and
you know saw my body just start to morph
which i
actually really really liked um and i i
really liked the effects
that this type of physical training was
having on my tennis performance
and um you know and then i i got into i
got into nutrition i got more into
weightlifting
i uh i don't think this served me too
well
in the whole functional realm of sports
performance but
i was super into rocky so i'd like watch
rocky films
and lift weights and exercise
and i started getting super into it like
even when i was like 14 or 15 um
you know my garage gym kind of morphed
into a pretty impressive little facility
and i i had a few mentors
in later years of high school a guy who
was a
professional bodybuilder who taught me a
whole bunch about nutrition and more
about lifting
another one of my dad's friends was the
washington state powerlifting champ so
he taught me
you know how to clean and how to
deadlift how to jerk and push press and
he taught he taught me all these moves
which
really amplified my performance in
tennis and
it got to the point where i went from
wanting to be
um kind of like an early high school
a computer programmer and video game
designer which
would probably would have made me like a
multi-billionaire by now i'd probably be
like some e-gamer
or or zuckerberg uh
but i instead uh walked on to
the college tennis team and declared a
major
in kinesiology which is basically like
you know glorified personal training but
you know study of biomechanics and and
uh human movement physiology
and then i got i got so into it
especially like that you know like we
were talking about earlier like a
physician will
study a lot of biochemistry and
microbiology and organic chemistry
i got so into that side of of science
after not being that interested in
science all through high school
um that i i decided i actually kind of
want to be a doctor
and so i took all the pre-meds
um got a master's degree in exercise
physiology and biomechanics
wow you know took the mcat one of
applying to medical school
got accepted to a bunch of medical
schools and
i actually decided to like take a gap
year
and work a year in the private sector
and and
part of that was because i just want
some time off after education and part
of it was because
i was looking at a couple of md phd
programs
that i didn't get accepted to and i was
kind of kind of pissed off about that
being my little
proud narcissistic college student self
and so
if you admit it it's okay you're not if
you admit it
yeah i guess so if the narcissist and mr
narcissist they're not a narcissist
exactly
um but then i uh i
might my work in the private sector was
i got a job in hip and knee surgical
sales
for this company called biomet and so
you know my job consisted of driving
around the doctor's offices and
and you know scrubbing down and
attending at surgeries with my little
laser pointer showing them where to
you know where to put the overpriced
hips and knees they were implanting and
morbidly obese patients who probably
through preventive medicine
wouldn't have had to overwhelm our
insurance system and and get
get all these implants put into their
body well these
you know rich doctors with their boats
and their cars complaining the whole
time about all the paperwork
that dictated that they didn't have time
to you know go and enjoy those fancy
boats and cars
the whole experience for me in like
modern
allopathic medicine kind of left a
little bit of a better taste in my mouth
and so
after like five months in that job i
quit
and kind of got back into health and
fitness which is all i'd done
in college you know i worked as a
personal trainer and a nutritionist all
through college
for timeline purposes like how oh that
was like 2005
or so so um so then
i i literally just like walked to the
athletic club
that was close to the apartment i was
living in and slapped down my resume and
asked for a job